[Music]
hi I'm Katie and I'm Colleen and we're
the chip sisters and today we're at
killer yard and we're learning how to
harvest mussels in Ireland
[Music]
Hilary Harper is a Ford located in the
West of Ireland in northern connemara
mussel farming started in Killary
harbour in the 1980s situate on the
majestic Killary fjord is Killary fewer
shellfish a family-owned business a few
or it is classified as a narrow body of
water with steep hills or mountains on
three sides
[Music]
[Music]
heavy rainfall for that of the year that
brings all of the nutrients which gives
us a nice sweet taste for the month
[Music]
whole process takes two and a half years
for harvesting time here that is amazing
and there how far down there about eight
meters deep Wow
before they're ready to cook the mussels
must first be put through an extensive
cleaning and sorting process these
special machines clean seaweed debris
and any unwelcome sea creatures from the
mussels
[Music]
of the 297 species of mussels only 17
are edible entirely
[Music]
[Music]